what we're going to do in this video is
introduce ourselves to the notion of a
definite integral and with indefinite
integrals and derivatives this is really
one of the pillars of calculus and as
we'll see they are all related and we'll
see that more and more in future videos
and we'll also get a better appreciation
for even where the notation of a
definite integral comes from so let me
draw some functions here and we're
actually gonna start thinking about
areas under curves so let me draw a
coordinate axes here so that's my y-axis
this is my x-axis actually I'm gonna do
two cases so this is my y-axis this is
my x-axis and let's say I have some
function here so this is f of X right
over there and let's say that this is x
equals a and let me draw a line going
straight up like that and let's say that
this is x equals B just like that and
what we want to do is concern ourselves
with the area under the graph under the
graph of y is equal to f of X and above
the x-axis and between these two bounds
between x equals a and x equals B so
this area right over here and you can
already get an appreciation we're not
used to finding areas where one of the
boundaries or as we'll see in the future
many of the boundaries could actually be
curves but that's one of the powers of
the definite integral and one of the
powers of integral calculus and so the
notation for this area right over here
would be the definite integral and so
we're gonna have our lower bound at x
equals a so we'll write it there we'll
have our upper bound at x equals B all
right over there we're taking the area
under the curve of f of X f of X and
then DX now in the future we're going to
especially once we start looking at
Riemann sums we'll get a better
understanding of where this notation
comes from this actually comes from live
knits one of the founders of calculus
this is known as the summa symbol
but for the sake of this video you just
need to know what this represents this
right over here this represents the area
under f of X between x equals a and x
equals B so this value and this
expression should be the same